Okay, welcome to another Zoom call, this is a reminder for all of us that God's is true
that it's more important than anything in our life than we need to stay focused on that
and stay in his work so that people talk a lot about faith and we got to make sure that our
faith is in him and not in anything else.
Just a reminder about that.
Okay, remind everybody to go to your member site, use your member site as your first order of business
and where you can access the courses, access the blogs, etc, etc.
Let's jump into the questions.
We got a need from TrueRife today that said we need to do an update so to write if you're
belong to their email list, they sent out an email saying update to the new 6.2 program.
I know we talked about this in the last big call.
You said not to do it, but is this something that do that needs to be done?
Well, right now, no, you do not need to update to the 0.2.
There's pros and cons to it.
You asked me last week, I'd say do not update to the 6.2.
Now, you know, they've fixed a lot of things.
So as I told you last week's Zoom call the week before was kind of a nightmare week for us
because nothing was working on the 6.2 program for us.
And I was on the phone with Jake, a good part of the week trying to get things fixed.
Well, hats off to them because they did some candy things to get things fixed.
So our programs would still work, would start working again.
So that is good.
So currently I'm very happy with the 6.2 program.
Although I didn't upgrade mine by right at home, I'm not upgrading it.
I think they still got bugs to work out currently with the 6.2.
You can't put it on anything on auto runs.
So that's still an issue that they're still trying to work out.
So the new 6.2 program is what we're talking about.
So currently everybody that's on this call is running the 6.0 program.
I'm looking at anybody on this call.
And I've already upgraded to 6.2 and no, I don't believe so.
If you want to upgrade to version 6.2, you would be better offsetting your computer.
And your right machine back to me and have me do it for you at this point in time.
If you have not upgraded to 6.2, I'd suggest you just wait a little until they get more of the bugs worked out because there are still some bugs in the program.
I do think it's going to be an overall ultimately.
And there may be a time that I get an upgrade to 6.2, but by that time they'll probably be on 6.3 or 6.4.
Maybe a couple of months.
Jake said they're working on 6.3 and 6.4 and that's going to be even a better upgrade.
I really liked some of the things that he mentioned.
We do have some of our new patients that are on 6.2.
Understand getting to your program on 6.2 is a little different.
So I have this important claim disclaimers that were the disclaimer, but information on the member site so you can look at it.
Also, I created a video for 6.2 users to get to their, what I call their master program, which is their personal program.
It's just a little bit different. You have to go to the, when you open up the true right program and you go to screen or the open program screen, which is really their home screen.
You won't see your program in it. You have to go to the left hand side and click on the documents folder and the documents folder you'll see a true right frequency file.
You have to click on that and you'll get to the program that I created for you.
It's an extra couple steps, which for if you're used to running 6.0, you're like, oh, there are two more steps.
You're not used to that. This is all brand new. It's no big deal.
Now with these people, I've also created a shortcut on their desktop for the easiest access. So if you do decide to upgrade or something happens to your computer, if your computer goes complete.
You can't even get 6.0 anymore. So we have to upgrade you to 6.2.
Which is fine, but then I will do that for you and I will create a shortcut on your desktop for you to just click on it and it'll open up your program.
So it'll save you from these other two steps that you would have to do in the 6.2 program.
Now that could all be changed again in the 6.4, 6.3. So just personally, I would not upgrade to 6.2.
Yeah, unless your computer goes completely, if your computer goes completely, then we don't have a choice.
And I would wait till they get some of the bugs worked out.
I am currently anemic, iron levels, iron saturation, ferritin, hemoglobin, magnesium to name a few.
What's a good source of iron supplementation? I'm taking an ancestral blood supplementation supplements right now.
Bolvide, grass fed, freeze dried products and familiar with these, these you could still use also the other thing that you could go on is a good source of iron as well.
This, the products that you are using right now are a, are a, it is an iron product, but it's, it's a, it's a whole food iron product which can be good and can be beneficial, but just getting iron in a source like I'm going to show you in just a second.
It might be something to add to the product. It's clear, I heard that I would say would be a choice and this is it right there. So clear, I heard is the, is the,
ferrochelle, that's the brand name, ferrochelle is this, is the,
designs for health uses ferrochelle and number of companies use ferrochelle. It is a product that is created as a, this glycinate double bonded member, all your minerals have to be double bonded to an amino acid.
And typically they use glycine because that's what's found in nature. So it's well absorbed and well used. However, if you're going to take iron, I always suggest that you add or to miss it and with it as well, because cancer can double up iron. That's why many cancer patients are low in iron and end up with anemia because the cancer is gobbling up iron.
So it seems counter to a tip that I'm going to add iron to help with my anemia if I could possibly be feeding the cancer. Well, it is. Well, you have to, we have to walk that tight rope.
You can't, you know, stay in anemic state. That's not good for us either and not good for our healing.
So if you're going to add iron, even the ancestral product that you're currently taking, I would say an Artemisidant as well, why Artemisidant because Artemisidant kind of tail wigs with iron and it will drag the iron will drag the Artemisidant with it to the cancer and Artemisidant can be a cancer killer.
Artemisidant is something that it goes right along with iron. It is carried with iron. So take Artemisidant along with your iron, if you're taking iron.
In one of your articles about decided whether or not to do Kibo, you talk about totally snow. Well, that's an old article. Isn't it actually wrote that in what I was writing by the first copy of my stop by the cancer book I think back in 2010.
And it was about Kibo that killed him not the tumors in his liver. What if you're doing all the natural alternative stuff diet supplements right and still get recurrence of tumors in your liver.
So I think the question is just because there's bad stories about Kibo should everybody avoid Kibo like the plague and the answer is no, absolutely not.
And sometimes Kibo is the right thing to do. It's the right thing to add your protocol. It's the right thing to help doubt the cancer. If you're doing the right, if you're doing other things to help build up your body, you can help prevent as much damage to your body as you possibly can while taking Kibo understands probably good chance.
Totally snow was not using the right machine and may have not been doing any natural things as well. A lot of people in public view stick right straight line to standards of care because they're afraid of the backlash that they get if they were doing anything alternative because they're more concerned with the public's view of them quite often.
At least that's what it seems like. So you are doing a lot of natural alternative things. If you do choose to do Kibo, you know, there's some other things that we want to do to protect you as well with Kibo following the Kibo protocol. And if you're in is, you know, what you're doing, I think already. So you're, you know, you're, you don't need you're going to have the same outcome is totally still. So I would agree.
I have been experiencing head and foot syndrome. This is a common syndrome as a Kibo side effect for Kibo damages your peripheral nerves.
And so, so Kibo's a toxic and it can, you know, why do people have peripheral nerve damage with Kibo more than central nerve damage with Kibo, well, you can have central nerve damage as well with Kibo, but
the reason why you have an increased possibility of peripheral nerve damage with Kibo is that as we age our, our, our circulation is not as good to even even with young people or circulation is not as good to the peripheral areas of our hands and our feet as it is to our core of our body.
So Kibo a toxin can settle in those areas and can cause all sorts of damage. That's why it's a syndrome because it could be a collection of symptoms.
So in you, it looks like it's causing blisters on your feet would it be good to continue foot baths or should I hold off on those and tell the blisters are resolved.
You don't, you do want to be careful with foot baths if you have an open wood.
If it's a blister and it's not an open wood, could you still do a foot bath? Technically, yes.
If you find that it causes irritation, when you do that to the area that's blister, then I'd say back off.
But if you're like, no, that doesn't make it worse than I'd say it would be better to continue to do them because you the foot bath can help pull those toxins out of your body.
Make sure you're supporting your liver. Make sure you're doing like hot packs over your liver. Make sure you're doing coffee animals. That's going to be the best thing to decrease head and foot syndrome with coffee animal with the chemotherapy is really supporting liver detox pathways.
Supporting flow, supporting the lymphatic flow, because that's really the issue. Remember, you don't have, you know, a heart that's pumping, you know, fluid through your lib vessels.
You're completely dependent upon the action of your muscles and gravity.
So we do is doing some lymphatic exercises, doing some, you know, just getting some better lymphatic flow.
And I have a bunch of videos on that and I think some blog posts on that too is going to be your best thing to do to help move those toxins out of the body through the liver, but then you have to be supporting your liver pathways.
And making sure that they're all the downstream pathways from there, your call letter and your, and your gut is open and you're having good ball movements and all that.
In liposomal vitamin C reach the cytotoxic levels of the vitamin C in the bloodstream that we need or even in the cells without doing it IV. I understand such levels.
As 340 to 400 milligrams per deciliter. Are there guidelines for calculating that, for example, taking 4.5 grams of liposomal vitamin C every X hours a day.
So the data that was studied with liposomal vitamin C was really looking at how much liposomal vitamin C do you need and how it would and the calculation of how much you need of liposomal vitamin C versus
you know, regularly ingested vitamin C. So the problem with, you know, you're trying to get IV vitamin C. So if you're IV, vitamin C levels, if you're wanting to get, let's say, 25 grams, how many grams of, you know, first of all, this years ago, we talked about, there wasn't very many IV centers to go to to get IV vitamin C.
So people would go, can I just take 25 grams of vitamin C orally? Well, the problem was at that time, this was before liposomal vitamin C really was on the market. If you took 25 grams of vitamin C orally, which you could get, you know, capsules and take 1000 milligram capsules, which is a gram and take 25 of those.
Could they just do that? That's a lot cheaper than going to an IV center and there isn't any aroma.
Well, the problem is you'd probably burn a hole in your stomach doing that or you'd get some stomach ingestion, you know, indigestion issues because of it's a scorpic acid.
And you can irritate your bleeding or your stomach over time doing that. Secondly, you're not going to have really good absorption. You'll probably only absorb about maybe one fifth of that.
So then, you know, with liposomal vitamin C, they found that if you took about one fourth to one fifth. So about 20 to 25 percent of that, you could get this same.
So if you took 25 grams of regular vitamin C, you're only going to absorb about five grams of it. So if you took five grams of liposomal vitamin C, it would be equivalent to taking 25 grams of regular vitamin C.
That's not really the calculation we're looking at. Yes, I think there really is an almost one to one ratio of taking liposomal vitamin C to doing IV vitamin C.
The problem is, is that if you want to take 25 grams of liposomal vitamin C, that can get costly too. Most vitamin C, let me look up vitamin C that are our
liposomal vitamin C is what's the gram dosage of a lot of the liposomal vitamin C out there. You're looking at you're looking at 1200 milligrams per teaspoon about that.
So you're still taking 25 teaspoons or 20 teaspoons that you're taking almost, you know, almost, you know, a bottle or half of the bottle, depending on what size bottle you're using. So it's still costing you 25. Still, I guess it is. I guess it's still way cheaper than doing an IV.
The benefit that I see with liposomal too is that you could, you know, you're going to do IV vitamin C, you're doing it a couple of times a week maximum with liposomal. I think there is there a benefit to, you know, doing it, you know, more often and maybe not as high a dose, but more often. If you went down to the cancer clinics in Mexico, they would only give you 15 grams of liposomal of IV vitamin C, but they do it daily.
If you go to an IV center here or cancer clinic here that's doing IVs, you might get 25 grams, you might get 50 grams, you might get 75 grams, but you're only doing that once a week, maybe twice a week.
So it's to do 75 grams of liposomal. That's like maybe maybe two bottles worth of boy, that's expensive, but it's still cheaper than going to an IV and you can split it up through the day. You're going to have as much cytotoxic benefit.
I think so because remember everything has a half life in the body. If you put 75 grams in the blood over an hour log drip, it's still going to be gone within a day.
You're not going to have much in there, maybe two days later, it's going to be gone. There's not going to be enough cytotoxic dosage. I still think that they're that, you know, there can be benefit to that super, super, super saturated dose using an IV.
But there can be even more benefit sometimes to getting up to treatment dose on a daily basis.
So it really is a one to one ratio. I think with liposomal vitamin C as far as grams goes to an IV vitamin C.
But now where the difference is is, you know, what is the best, you know, super saturated dose? What is the best cytotoxic dose for a cancer patient?
A lot of the Mexico cancer clinics I tend to agree with because the lower dose more frequently. I know some of the clinics up here that it stays to a higher dose less frequent.
Maybe there's benefit to both. I don't know what date is out there showing the difference between those.
Dr. Connors, may I comment on that please?
I was, I was going to do the Reardon protocol, which is basically they start you out at 12 grams, then to 25, then to 50 grams.
And then during the off days, they have you take one gram of liposomal every four hours and somehow, and then they measure your blood.
Yeah, that's my understanding. Yes. And then they, they, they take your blood to see if you're at the 340 to 400 milligram per deciliter concentration.
And somehow it's, there's some cumulative effect so they can actually do it twice a week and have that work out. I don't know. I've never done it, but I'm going to try it beginning tomorrow.
See, that kind of fits with my light of thinking. So they're giving you the IB to kind of get you get your tissues saturated and then they have you followed up doing daily life was almost so that makes sense.
It even makes more sense if they're objectively measuring it.
I think that, you know, it might be cheap because I can get with an announce I can get 4.5 grams of liposomal vitamin C orally, and I can do that like four times a day or whatever it is.
And I was even thinking of having them measure the density in my blood just on liposomal alone and see what we can achieve just as an experiment because I couldn't find.
You're the first person that said the one the one ratio. I looked all over to find some kind of answer to that and I couldn't find one.
Well, I think it's a pretty close to one to one ratio IV to liposomal. It's not IV to taking a vitamin C, a scorpic acid pill.
Understood.
Okay, thank you so much.
It really is based on how much you absorb.
So obviously when you do an IV you're getting it directly into bloodstream.
If you're taking it orally, how much are you actually absorbing with liposomal, you're really absorbing the majority of it.
So that's the benefit of the life was almost.
Thank you.
I will email you blood results when I get them back, but my hemoglobin is 8.3.
So when you talk about ademia, you want to look at your red blood cell cubs,
like this question up here.
You're looking at iron saturation, ferritin, and then you're looking at red cell with RDW.
There's other things that you're looking at to find out what type of ademia it is.
But when you're really talking about concerns with ademia,
you're really talking about hemoglobin.
So that's your biggest concern as far as how many symptoms you're going to have from ademia.
That's all you really need to look at as far as, you know, how is it affecting my life?
Because it was your hemoglobin drops down, especially if it drops down into the eights or the sevens or lower,
then you're going to start having some fatigue.
So like ad, when you said your hemoglobin is still at 10,
you might not really be experiencing a whole lot of symptoms at that point.
But when your hemoglobin stripes starts to drop down into the eights or the sevens, the sixes,
that's when you're going to really start feeling some fatigue.
And this goes back to that same question about iron demand to be careful with iron.
Yes, and no, as you're certainly with the hemoglobin of the low eights,
you definitely want to start iron, but you want to add artimicidid.
And I know who asked this question, please schedule a time to talk with me tomorrow,
because I want to talk to you about some other things.
I'm taking prohydroxychobolamine.
So prohydroxychobolamine is the B12 component.
Part of your anemia is tied to B12 anemia.
So there's different types of anemia.
It can be anemia of chronic disease, which you usually see in cancer patients,
because the cancer is kind of gobbled up the iron.
But you could also have anemia B12 anemia.
There is a totally different component that really is a comorbidity of cancer patients.
It's a cause of B12 anemia is necessarily tied to any causation of cancer.
This is the artimicidid that I'd recommend.
You know, in general, it's research.
It's research on artificial artimicid and solo.
And if you're in general, you're going to take one capsule of my or take one to two of these,
if you're going to take a couple,
if you're going to take iron a couple times a day with certainly with hemoglobin in the eights,
Clear iron, probably three a day, then you take three to six are the
Artemisin and so you take one to two of these every time you take an iron capsule.
I do not feel as if my right machine is making a positive difference in my
healing process. Are you able to update by frequencies? Also, why is Monday not
shown as an option in the daily settings? Oh, good question. Why Monday's not
shown? I don't know. The most common reason why a person loses a program is because they
accidentally would click it on it, dragged it somewhere. We've seen that if we
see that once we've seen it a hundred times, it's really easy to do by accident.
You're accidentally drag a program and you don't realize it. You go where's my problem?
Or you could drag the whole folder into another folder. You could drag the program into another
program. You could drag it into another folder. It's all sorts of different things.
But the Monday did not be there. It's almost impossible. It's almost impossible for you to delete it.
You'd have to right click hit delete and then say, yes, I want to delete it. So nobody does that.
I'd have to look at that and we might have to look at your program. Yes, we can update your
frequencies. Absolutely. We should do a cheek swab. Make sure that you're not just doing the right.
Make sure you're doing the recommended nutrition and supplements and diet along with it.
As always, we don't think the right is a magic one. It's using frequencies to help heal you and
helps stimulate an immune response. But if you're not doing other things to stimulate an immune response,
it's going to have less effects. So we want to do as many things as we possibly can,
dealing with as many facets of your health as you possibly can.
So answer to that. We should probably do another cheek swab and make sure we're on that right track.
Glory dioxide has been touted in some internet discussion circles as an effective cancer cure.
Or most writings refer to it as a disinfectant. I found only one reference to it on the clinic site
and it is not sold in the store. Do you have any credible information
indicating chlorine dioxide even in small amounts as a cancer reducer? The substance usually
contains sodium chloride. So wouldn't it be poisonous even in low concentrations? Could a
curative claim be snakewood? I'm not so so so chlorine chloride dioxide has also been sold as
MMS miracle mineral solution.
Would you talk about something as just like this cure all for everything which unfortunately
I think it was discarded. His last name is humble, which is kind of odd because he wasn't very humble,
but he went around pushing MMS as a cure all for everything. And yes, I think it was just
snake oilish. I think it was really bad. But the sad thing is is you know in all these things,
there's some little truth to it. So when we saw a lot of line patients, I used to use MMS
with line patients and there was some effectiveness with it. I think it had benefit. I think it does have
benefit in killing pathogens. But when you say, oh yeah, here's the cancer treatment with MMS.
I just can't imagine the metabolic pathway that it would be working to kill cancer.
And the cancer protocol with it is so high that there could be toxic levels.
And it's just really concerned me. We took it off the store years ago. I still used to sell it in
my office for a long time for my line patients. We took it off the store years ago because the FDA
just really really came down on it and I realized that sometimes when the FDA comes down on something,
it's probably a good thing to use. But I'm not a big fan of chloride dioxide for cancer.
I still think it has a lot of efficacy killing pathogens. And I think there was efficacy of it using
it for COVID in viruses. But boy, there anybody who was pushing chloride dioxide during COVID was just
hammered big time by the FDA. I'm talking about clinics or physicians that were posting anything.
They're just, our country is getting worse and worse as far as what you could actually say.
We're going to be losing our YouTube channel pretty soon at these videos. We have to figure out
a different platform to post these videos. But understand we're saving all of our all our stuff
is saved. So we're worried about losing data. But YouTube is there they're canceling an average
of video a week of ours. Stupid erroneous things. It's just ridiculous. Their AI is picking up all
sorts of stuff that they're canceling. Then you see some videos on just garbage on the false claims
on YouTube all the time. So I have no idea what type of what they have programmed into their
AI to pick up bad videos or false claim videos. Yes, I don't think chloride dioxide has a lot
efficacy or cancer. I do think it has some efficacy for pathogens. Had an appointment with my
ecologist today, he gave me just months to live. Okay, so that bothers me right there. It bothers me
multiple reasons. Just hurts me horribly. It hurts me horribly that somebody would even say that.
How do they know? If they think, oh boy, we just did a scan and it looks really bad. You don't
you just say, okay, this looks bad. We need to change something. We need to do some things. But if he
hasn't no other tools in his tool bay, then he needs to say, okay, I don't have any tools in my tool bag
for this. Here's one I can offer. Look at other things. You know, talk to your alternative doctors.
Good to say. I just hate it. It's just just just just hurts me when you hear things like that. They
don't know things. Here's your Bible verse right here. God's word is alive and active and sharper than
any two-inch sword that your oncologist might use to hurt you and even if you have four months to live,
five months to live, ten months to live, that's not for somebody to say, how do you know? How do they
know? They don't know. They're not God. God is God. And you might, you know, I might get run over,
driving home today. My faith is going to be in him, in him alone, not in some lab tests, not in some
therapy that they have or don't have to offer. We have to trust in that alone.
Okay, changed my chemo and may have radiation on my hips. By right side towards the side of my rib cage,
I have pain when I take a breath, a deep breath. So probably something in your ribs, for sure,
hurts at night. Of course, so could be inflammation in your ribs and in the muscle, in the intercostal
muscles as well. He said there can be a glove like a rod deliver. Is there some way to relieve this?
Yes. Once cancer has met the bones, can it ever heal? Yes, we probably have people on this call
that have had cancer to the bones, maybe not on this call. I can't see everybody who's out here.
That, you know, have been alive for years, you know, I have patients that have been with me for
over 15 years now. And we're in this situation when they came to me. He thinks it's in the bow
marrow. We'll send the cheek swab. Is there a way to beat this cancer? He's never, never give up. You
just keep doing things. You keep changing things. You keep making tweaks that you need to make that
is going to be best for you. Make sure we talk tomorrow. So call Mary to get out of the schedule so
we can talk tomorrow. You just don't give up. Whenever you hear bad news like that from somebody who's
touting bad news, please, please, please, everybody listen to me. You got to say in the name of Jesus, I'm
not going to accept that. God knows my outcome. He knew me before I was born, before I was put in my
mother's womb. He knew me and he knows all the days of my life are numbered. I him. So I'm not going
to accept that. I'm not going to accept that at all. That's that I'm going to, you know, think that
I'm going to overcome it myself, but I'm going to overcome anything that God has for me
through him. So make sure you put that out of your mind. Okay, other questions here. Are you familiar
with Zolaire for chronic Lyme and autoimmune? I know some will take you to it and her food sensitivities
are disappearing. No, I'll have to look that up. Zolaire. Okay, I'm not familiar with that. I will look
that up. And the product, uh, aloevia entourage, be used as a substitute for the clear PC. Yes, they are
both. They are both CBDs. So yes, you can't. So look at the dosage of clear PC. You probably have
them in front of you. And, you know, compare it to the dosage of the torch. Yep. After my surgery,
do I run my life with my cancer programs at night as usual? And the other suggested after surgery
programs during the day, do I cycle through the seven or are so recommended programs? No, just,
yes, run your cancer programs as usual during the day. And then you can do the other ones to use,
run your cancer programs as usual at night. And you can run the other programs during the day. Extra
prayer requests for my surgery seven a.m. He starts dead or to the time to the, okay, they can
open that. So I remember to pray for you tomorrow. And please, everybody be prayed for this person who
got such a bad comment from their oncologist. Well, I heard is 117. My red blood cells are very low.
What does that mean? I thought I heard red blood cells are connected. Yes, they can be. They
often are. I need to look at all your blood work in order to make an assessment of that. So if you can
send that to me, if you did already, then we should probably schedule a time to chat. Spell the
aren't emissited. I think I put that up there after you said that. Jim Hubble just passed away.
It cures malaria effectively. I agree. I think that, you know, we have great results. This person
is talking about the, um, the chlory dioxide. Again, um, we did have good results with, um, it's, uh,
um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, and I still recommend line patients to use it. So I'm not
against, I'm just against them. Making over claims. I, I would have been getting, I, you know, how much I
believe in the right. But if I was sitting here saying the right cures everything, I don't think you
should listen to me because that's just not right. And it's so bothers me. And I just had a
moment talking to Marie about this today because I've talked to her about it about every week.
It's coming to get sick of me. But it bothers me about these Instagram because I, I like Instagram.
And I like to look at a lot of gardening things on Instagram and stuff like that and YouTube and such.
And, um, but when you see these quote-unquote nutritionists that are making these claims about things,
you have to be really careful about that stuff. It can get you down too when you're doing it because
they, they're all they're trying to do is get followers and, and this, you know, clickbait stuff
to get you to click on stuff. But that you just, you gotta be careful with some of the information
that's out there because a lot of it is hyper exaggerated and a lot of it is wrong. And it's just
misinformation. So you've got to be careful with some of that too. That's, well, I just, I want to be
and I pray daily that I'm a voice of reason for everybody. So, you know, bounce stuff off of me. If I
don't know something, I'll tell you I don't know. But I, you know, but I'll try to be a balancing
act. If I think something is wrong, I'll tell you maybe why I think it's wrong, but I'm totally
open to being corrected. So, um, I think that's what we all need. We need, you know, that, you know,
we need those kind of, we need people in our life. The Bible says, Iron Sharpen's Iron. So we need people
in our life that will sharpen us. And, um, I hope I'm back to you. You guys are certainly that to me.
So, um, I think that's how we grow and that's how we can best all work together to help each other
overcome this world and in everything that we do. So, let's keep our trust in God and God alone
and and ask for knowledge so that we can use that knowledge wisely to help ourselves
fight the evils of this world. And one of those is sickness. And so we need to, we struggle against sickness
because of the fall. And it is in the world and and just like any struggles in this world and evils
in this world, we do need to struggle against it. We will struggle against it until God comes back
again. So Jesus returns. Um, so we know that's going to be a daily thing that we struggle against.
But we don't have to do it alone. So we do that together and we struggle together. But we have to
know that even in the struggles God uses those and desires to use those in our life to mold us and shape
us more to the image of this son on a daily basis. Sometimes I'll be honest, that's not at all evident
in my life. And I just pray that I can allow my difficulties to mold me and shape me to the image
of him and trust in him more dearly every single day. So I pray that is for you as well. All right,
thanks for the questions today. Um, make sure you get your questions in. If you can ahead of time,
please do so. Every little question. Is it silly questions? So don't feel bad about doing that.
All right, love you all. I will see you guys next week. Bye-bye.